what's up Chris and Matt my name is
Brian McCready and I live in Chicago uh
you're a serial killer dude yeah I
thought that right when I saw him
actually have you ever done voice
exercises or
you are an actual serial killer and
Chris
I know that you have silky smooth
vibrato
drunk
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
right hopefully people are stabbing each
other this episode
is that cool Anthony
yeah
no actually yeah it was asleep woke up
said that and then got so angry that I
woke him up dude honestly let's start
the show like this Andrew
whatever your name is
Antonio
Andy dude you you're and it's Anthony
we're joking you're editing
your
everything is on point
you don't don't say hi people right you
know what Matt was saying when we got
terrible Anthony this is how Anthony
says hi huh yeah yeah well more of her
sorry interject but and nobody here does
greetings correctly are we [__] even
recording yeah we are okay uh I nobody
does greeting correctly I walk in both
of their [__] backs are to me if they
say hi I can't hear it because they're
talking the [__] wall on their
computers you walk in are looking down
and you say hey one time
for everybody there's three of us here
well I mean what the [__] am I a
politician hi how you doing hi how you
doing dude I'm nice I walked in I'm like
what's up Anthony what's up Chris this
is looking at their [__] computers
you walk in you looking at the ground
you say hey okay there is a level of
Look Alive intimacy there is a level of
closeness there is a level of connection
that you have with people where you are
now blessed to be in their life and
they're blessed to be in yours okay so
act like and when you and when you
graduate to that level you don't need to
do anything but sup and that's the level
we've been at by the way for years
you've never mentioned but I don't like
it it's it's like now all of a sudden
you don't like it's life denying look
what I'm trying to figure out life
denying
dad
all right listen
started a two-hour School Chris is up
there trying to do the time in it anyway
that didn't help anybody understand what
yeah and he's well it helped a little
bit dude it's a clock and it lets us
know how long we've gone so far he
didn't start it when we started and he
was doing it like my dad would do it
which is very badly and slowly and
pointing the remote way too close as if
it's not an actual remote you need to be
proxy uh uh approximately oh dude I hate
when people do like this with the Shazam
I do that I do that hey but sound is
everywhere no it's not there's more up
there are you kidding me yes it is it's
close if you get closer to the source
it's louder and clearer that's how the
Sound Works dude when you're just in a
room yes
all right if it's a quiet room and you
do that sure but it's like restaurants
and [__] Poca phase it's Pokemon
restaurants and [__] I do it
that's so that doesn't work shut up dude
the difference between here
and here here doesn't work you don't go
not not poke Cafe
I'm tall and I get it close and I never
miss with Shazam
when I'm down on the ground I don't get
it sexual listen
um
so Anthony good job on editing first of
all already good job on editing I know I
was making fun of you the last episode
about how you don't do it quick enough
already good good job and then you took
the note
when what did you say to him last
episode I said he doesn't ever remember
I don't remember so so what he does is
what he did was I would be like Barry
Bonds and then we'd be talking about
Barry Bonds and then Barry Bonds would
come up right dude he did it a little
bit a little bit kind of trolling me did
it before we were talking about the
thing now okay a little bit trolling but
but dude he was killing it I watched it
and I love when he does like he did one
thing I was talking about too close you
too close I know and you smacked it go
ahead and he he added oh cool
it's just great dude and then he does
like when I show him get it up [__] he
zoomed it in okay anyway I'm getting a
cityscape but why are your [__] nails
like that I'm Punk now are you a guy
named Brett in eighth grade when I was
in eighth grade so deeper are you a guy
named Kevin Anderson a guy that [__]
your girl for sure when you were no dude
Kevin Anderson was a friend of mine and
mom didn't like him and she made me feel
so bad when I would hang out with him
wow and now he's a park ranger why were
you naughty why are you so naughty you
know
Mommy why were you so naughty your
therapist told you to use the episodes
you confront your mom and you're so
[__] up in that David Mommy why are
you so naughty so bad smell my coffee
everywhere yes dude I call Mom and I say
Mommy why are you so naughty and then I
hang up yeah yeah so listen
um
all right listen man let's talk about
mom used to do mom used to [__] uh
say to me why do you only hang out with
the foreign kids and not as a racist
Prejudice thing because
their parents didn't speak English so
she was like I can't even be friends
with the [__] yeah but moreover you
would hang out with not just foreign
because the weirdest yeah different
different kids and and different was
foreign because right I mean different
because because it was well yes they are
weirdos but but the main thing is I
wanted them to be not the standard Brad
Chuck you know Vince I wanted him to be
I wanted him to be like Idis like my
friends was nice no he was nice as [__]
but his parents were like we don't know
where we are you know yeah and he had a
sister who really this is weird I
remember he had a sister who was
beautiful but she looked exactly like
him
and so it was like I couldn't figure out
what how I felt about her I'm gonna go I
want to take this a step further this is
something I think about sometimes okay
there are beautiful women out there
that so far I'm with you that if they
look like they're
dads or brothers too much I can't
I dated a girl for a long time who
looked exactly like your dad and you're
okay with it yeah and I knew the dad for
a long time before I even got together
with her oh I couldn't do it I I don't
think I could and and now I'm married to
the dad they uh you married you married
the devil okay so see so that's why you
can do it I love you Jimmy Jimmy
um that's his name
so yeah so so you can do it I I can't do
it I mean it is
it can be like disconcerting but it just
depends on how
how like strongly they resemble the
person so and who you saw first so you
saw the dad first well no I mean I knew
him okay I knew the yeah yeah it's just
it's a lot so what do you so I've been
thinking about that and I was like I
think that's a thing that must be a me
thing what thing no I think that's
pretty common really yeah like if the
daughter what like looks like no because
I'm telling you I the dad that I ever
have but like I couldn't actually
date someone like that if they look well
what give me they look too much like
somebody I already knew in their family
like like she had a brother yes and you
knew the Brotherhood matter if you knew
the brother first no Well if I knew her
for first first it would be okay okay
right okay but no if I met the brother I
could not do it yeah that's that's weird
that's not that's yeah right okay right
that's not right right
um that's not right in fact it's wrong
okay
so anyway yes I'm going to be in
Louisiana at the uh I'm going to be the
worst Segway yeah or absolute [__]
worse right and that's tonight anyway uh
if you want a one-on-one session with me
your boy
baby go to matilda.com Tuesdays and
Thursdays
[Laughter]
there's a lot in there I think we could
maybe work it maybe make it a little
more simple I throw them all out yeah
and I let the public decide so bad
that's the kind of thing I do but yeah I
go like that I throw them all out but I
didn't know I didn't say I didn't finish
what I was saying which is interesting
about Louisiana because no one cares no
so maybe in Louisiana Louisiana tonight
and then I'm gonna be in uh New York
Rhode Island Chicago that's already sold
out that's real wow such an [__] uh
two shows at the Beacon Theater hmm 2800
seats so that's a dilemma right because
it's gonna be six thousand people so
what do we do are they sold out the
second one is not but yeah [__] [__]
um don't tell people to buy tickets for
things that are sold out okay yeah
you're right so not Chicago so not
Springfield in Missouri so hmm um well
it would help if my things were up there
right now right for you so if you knew
if you had it I will be in uh
Minneapolis I will be in um a bunch of
different places and it would be so
helpful if they were out but they're not
right so Cincinnati uh Columbus God will
be so helpful but it's not it's okay
um and then Utah I will be in and then
uh nope we already passed that and then
uh Kansas City Tulsa Midland Texas
Austin I got two shows on sale there
Milwaukee and uh yeah there we go all
right cool boy Boise Salt Lake City no
we don't do that so chrisley.com get
your ticket and touch me and dude here's
the thing Dude too uh how about you
subscribe to the super good channel
right that's what we do dude and uh and
that's what's up that is what's up I'm
in green I'm in all green I mean you are
it's like you're uh in a war zone
casualties of War dude casualties of War
oh wow yes yes
[Music]
okay
that was the obvious that was the
weirdest thing I've ever seen you do
dude uh I was doing pull-ups oh you were
yeah actually doing it okay cool so
anyway I'm glad to do this we did not we
did a we did two shows two weeks ago and
we did not see each other last week
because I was on the road no on the road
again on a road again on the road again
[Music]
who's that guy that used to do all the
parts of the songs he beatboxed and he'd
also rap yeah and everybody acted like
it was the craziest thing ever and it
was the craziest thing ever but it also
sucked me yeah yeah who was that guy the
guy from Police Academy no it was
Roselle Roselle dude remember Razzo dude
he would be like
it was so crazy because what he does is
crazy but it sucks
[Music]
if your mother only knew dude wow
Cynthia
all right that outfit is so dope
this is crazy
[Music]
the person who posted it the beatbox
Queen
this is when it gets really sick yeah
you got to tease it out first
[Music]
see so shaky
on a plane recording it on a plane GoPro
on their head yeah
okay let's get to it
Russell
the reason why he's teasing it so much
is because honestly it's cool but who
cares and he has to tease it to get to
the part because it's like who gives a
[__] what he's doing it no it's too long
it's the kind of thing that it's
impressive but like who cares I have a
theory about this who likes it though no
it's not
here we go
at the same time
[Applause]
wow so cute
thank you
when you're talented at something that
only
is the thing you can't use it any other
news of life that thing sucks break
dancing number one thing like that
doesn't help for any other yeah but I
mean yeah sure yeah you do this you're
good at that who gives a [__] you could
be in a police academy remake right oh
to go to the part with it obviously the
part where
yeah
here we go oh
is this Wu-Tang
or is he doing this still
here we go
how are you doing that
[Music]
I'm looking you know
you have a camera on you I know it
you don't need to get attention when you
have a camera
I mean you know all right dude showing
himself up good job right so that's cool
that he can do that but also who cares
it's just that's what breakdowns it's
actually not who cares I do find it
impressive it's just like it sucks to
listen to yeah it's like wow you can do
that and that's impressive as [__] and
truly wow but like
it sucks
like I'd rather listen to a song
[__] bad well it's basically that but
anyway dude whatever dude you know
having a stroke the way your face looked
when you did it so anyway I'm having a
good time and we have a good time and
we're doing having a good time
what happened to your nails oh yeah I'm
parked now so I I did it because so
here's why I did it this is a story I
did it three and a half years ago for a
television show
elephant in the room yes I got cut out
of it now
kept them there I actually kind of
fancied them a little bit never did it
again
fine then one day I was like you know
what I'm gonna actually do it again
because I'm not because like Calvin
asked you or something like and there we
go hey hello I'm not to leave the story
Ruiner so so I so I'm like I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna get the black nail polish
and maybe I'm gonna do it I get it I get
the bike nail polish and then I'm like I
bet I you know I have it around my house
for a few weeks
and I'm like I bet Gavin would kind of
like this so as Kristen to do this she
does it and uh I show Calvin you know he
doesn't really give a [__] but I kind of
did a little bit for him but then now
what I realize is dude I pick my cuticle
so much but when I have the nail polish
on I only picked the nail polish my my
fingers have never been so healthy
because of this [__] tasting something
so so what so I think I'm not gonna keep
doing it because it's really annoying
because when I post Clips on the
internet of me doing stand-up people are
like really dude you would have flamed
somebody who did this when it's like no
I wouldn't the black fingers who gives a
[__] also I find people for everything
wow sleeper
well it's like I'm my own person no do
you know are you done yeah oh you are
quite done yet I'm probably not gonna do
it again soon but okay we're Storyteller
of all time worst ending you know uh and
then I died do you know do you know what
this is about no I don't Patsy you're
uncultured it's from adverb I know okay
what is that oh it's a show oh yeah wow
I haven't thought about that show in a
bit yeah with the pros dude yeah that's
funny is it really yeah it is because
usually those shows people are like oh
this is so funny BBC shows yeah yeah but
like Faulty Towers
I I know dude and it's like sacrilege to
do that when you're in comedy but it's
like well I'm not in comedy and I well
you are take my lucky stars for that
okay I'm not dude no way am I no no not
a part of that no thank you thank you
don't even like watch this Daniel comedy
even though you do it thank you that's
very rude
it's very rude to say the reason I watch
yours is because you're my brother thank
you very much you have to actually come
out and see me soon don't actually like
go in there ever never did and never
ever wanted to go thank you okay you're
being
because I would have felt bad if I
didn't go thank you so [__] rude you
why don't you like stand up I don't
like here's the honest truth okay same
reason I don't like comedy movies I
laughed so much in my life I don't need
to go sit down to watch people make me
laugh even more oh so you admit that it
is funny sometimes of course oh wow I
don't like sit there with a straight
face like a different front row in the
front room no I a lot whenever I'm there
I laugh I got you okay but yeah no it's
just I don't like it and I never did
okay now get off my back about it no I'm
not on your back about it okay well um
so should we do another should we do a
video now or what should we should we
see what's up let's get into the show
let's get into the nitty-gritty the nuts
and bolts
the nooks and crannies yep what's up man
eating cute wow
um
we are some we like to have a syllabus
time as you guys know you know us
I want to be high you guys know this
personally and
I we want to know if you guys get this
sometimes these annoying reactions when
like like we're also loud laughers yeah
as you guys know us
oh my God I'm gonna have nightmares
thanks people I found this real life
with like a strange will come and be be
like you guys have too much fun oh yeah
oh we're like oh you guys you better
quiet down
fine like just so [__] annoying and
then the vibe's gone yeah
it's done it's done by Washington okay
wow wow now the fun is actually over
oh evil so she's a demon Shelly is not a
demon the first girl I didn't catch her
name is a demon the one on the right
yeah yeah the one who did the bulk of
the talk oh wow dude that was making me
laugh she was making me laugh but I will
tell you this that sucks when people do
that and here's what they they always do
it in places where it's actually okay to
laugh it's never like well no okay so
one time we were laughing so hard at
Islands the restaurant in Glendale and
some guy comes over and he's like I'm
trying to have dinner with my family and
you're being really loud
yeah dude and I was like you're at
Islands dude there's literally a toucan
up here there's like a [__] paper
mache toucan above you like you're not a
you know what I mean you're not out at
like a nice restaurant or a library dude
we're laughing having a good time and he
was like and then he was like yeah well
you're too loud and and then he stood up
and walked over and he's like you guys
need to be quiet and I said to him I
actually said I said sir you don't want
me to stand up wow yeah dude she was
short too wow is that is that why he
didn't want it because you were gonna
make him feel bad for being short and
also it would have led to could have
could have led to no fisticuffs we don't
fight I don't fight but but he was
walking over getting in my face oh okay
so obviously I you know I was at a
disadvantage because I was like this but
he was short yeah but he was short but
but when I was sitting down he was a
taller when I stood up he would have
been okay I understand how that works
yeah so I just different depending on
your position sure yeah the worst worse
than that is when you have a loud laugh
and you're laughing and someone you're
with width of like a comrade an ally
tells you to shush or that's the worst
or okay it wasn't that funny well
there's nothing worse than that that's a
different category okay because then
you're just like you're like a he you're
like a homing
device for ruining you yeah you know
what I mean like you say that two ruined
moves I hate that dude but when people
go shh they think you're like upsetting
the vibe in a public place or something
like it's like they're panicked they're
like
and it's like what I'm laughing and I'm
enjoying myself people are gonna like
that I'm doing that if anything they're
probably not even gonna notice though
but honestly sometimes it is too loud
I've never once thought that in my life
okay all right I mean people when
they're talking are too loud but not
when they're laughing dude sometimes
people are so [__] loud huh what I
really don't like when people talk about
it it's just like we're all in the same
room what are you doing what I don't get
is there there's a way to talk how come
you don't get it you don't you don't
hear yourself there's people that are
soft or too loud I mean actually
honestly probably they probably don't
realize they're too loud because they
have a hearing issue or something you
think so yeah why else would you be that
mad I I I dated this woman and she was
just always too loud and I was just like
you're too loud and she was like really
she's like no you're too loud and I'm
like you're up pretty loud yeah but when
I'm allowed it's loud by Design it's on
purpose that's even worse no it's not
because I know where I am I'm either
like in a room full of people holding
Court getting the yucks out of them or
I'm like on stage ripping it okay well
nobody's saying you're too loud on stage
actually there are people who say that
okay well I'm one of them I think you're
too loud on stage no I'm just kidding
but uh yeah I've I have I mean it's
mostly men who I know are too loud one
of my friends in particular is like
I want to not be friends with them yeah
oh you shouldn't yeah I'm not I'm not
anymore
so yeah I I uh I think that uh it's okay
to laugh and have a good time but here's
the deal in the back of your head even
though you're laughing having a good
time how about this this is the rule
always know where you are and be aware
of other people I think that that's a
huge key of it and if you just keep that
in the back of your head I think that
things will probably work out a little
bit better for you and the people
because you don't want your vibe to get
ruined right because the bottom line is
you don't want your vibe to get ruined
but well here's the thing if people are
coming up to these two women and saying
[__] like what did they say that they
said hey you're laughing too loud you're
too loud say something mean back to them
there's nothing Ruder than being like
you're enjoying yourself too much you're
fat like this you're enjoying yourself
too much you're short you're ugly yeah
you're too that is it you're too zitty
yeah two zitty you're too City
you're too City you're two cities all
right cool A Tale of Two City
awful you know what I'm saying you your
podcast should be gone now because you
said that A Tale of Two City yeah no
it's good all right it should be the
title of the episode no let's do another
one all right
you guys so I have a such a pleasant
plenty of problem I'm hoping you can
help me out but uh me and my boyfriend
have been together for over four years
we've been living together for one and
recently has been telling me that I am
mean to him in my sleep oh wow so I
normally go to bed a bit earlier than
him so when he gets into bed I'm already
asleep and when he tries to cuddle up
and get close he says that I make these
angry noises and
um that I am just angry and rude to him
and I'm not conscious of any of this yep
um the only way I even know what's
happening is because he'll tell me in
the morning yeah
um and of course I don't want to be mean
uh but what can I do I would appreciate
your thoughts thank you guys well you're
not being mean when you're asleep you're
not awake you secretly hate them you're
subconsciously very active when you're
sleeping no you hate him you don't even
know what's happening and you can't be
held responsible for things when you're
sleeping there are actually cases where
people have killed people while they're
sleepwalking and they don't go to jail
because come on they were yeah I saw
that they didn't go to jail no whoa
you're not responsible for something
that you don't know that you're doing it
yeah but then don't yeah but okay you
have to either be willingly or knowingly
killing someone I think honestly what if
you get if you kill someone in your
sleep and you get off and you don't have
to go to jail you still have to go to
sleep jail you have to sleep in jail
that's [__] crazy no when do you go
to sleep you are in jail that's what I'm
saying
no I thought you said when you go when
you go to sleep you have to go to jail
in a jail I'm saying when you're asleep
you dream of being oh you didn't say
dreams that was obvious but you didn't
say dream right it pissing me off
you're so stupid and I understand what I
said how is that you didn't say
Obviously you use the same word
but I was obviously saying something
different because you had just said
something so if I say something
different it's not going to be the exact
same thing you said why not we always do
that no never yes we do dude what I said
was literally our dad always does that
yeah but not me yes you do dude we do
that no I don't do it
dude you can't be mad at me for using I
used certain words in the sentence I
said when you go to sleep I don't even
get to talk I said when are you going to
get the dog I said when you go to sleep
you're in jail you said you go to jail
when you go to sleep
what
no there are different things and you
know how they're different things the
words are a different [__] order yeah
but you didn't say the word dream which
is the key element to the [__]
sentence dude I didn't want to say I
left it out anyway you know it's true no
and later on I knew it was true
everything I do every note was the same
undo it found you know do you know wow
did you know that deaf I do it for you
dude you honestly [__] that up royally
nah because you go to sleep nah and then
you you have to go check into jail to
sleep is what I'm saying that's what
you're saying and what you're saying is
you go to sleep in jail say in jail
so bad all right
so I think that that's where you need to
go to sleep you need to go to a [__]
State pen to to go to sleep because you
or if you do that but also for you for
the young for the young lady
you hate him break up with him no dude
the guy has to [__] grow a nut sack
and understand that when someone's
asleep they're not themselves like
you're taking it personally God not
yourself like when you sleep you're just
like hello how are you dude when you go
home when you go to cuddle someone who
normally wants to cuddle but when
they're sleeping they're like Ah that's
not them that's true that's just I mean
what a [__] idiot that's the truth no
you're the true you when you're sleeping
no you're really stupid for saying that
you're really stupid the end
no dude
yeah I was gonna say stupid for saying
that but then I stopped short and just
said you're really stupid you ever wake
up and you got a A like a bone doggy
yeah yeah that's that's like the true
you buy a lot so stupid you don't know
you're that horny you wake up you go oh
[__] I didn't know it's not that you're
I guess the real me was horny it's not
that you're horny it's the more there's
like a thing called morning wood you
wake up with it I mean the guy talking
to me there's a thing called morning
wood I know that's like being like
that's like a [__] Tom Hanks was like
yeah I was in a little movie called
Saving Private Ryan I don't know if you
know it I know what morning wood is dude
saving Ryan's privates
dude you make the worst joke it's not
true
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
the best version of myself comes when I
feel centered and relaxed and anxiety
free
and when I'm at my best I can do great
things okay
and that's pretty much that's true for
anybody sometimes life gets you bogged
down and you may feel overwhelmed or
like you're not showing up in the way
that you want to I've been there I know
you have too yes and here's something
that can help working with a therapist
they can help you get closer to the best
version of you they certainly might help
you get to the best version of me
when you feel empowered you're more
prepared to take on everything life
throws at you if you're thinking of
going to therapy
give it a try but better help is the
best option it's a great option to do it
better help works it's convenient here's
why it's good they're flexible they're
affordable this is the best part they're
entirely online and all you got to do is
just fill out a very brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and uh the cool thing is if you don't
like the one they match you up with even
which you will you can switch and with
no it's no additional charge like it's
just they find you the right match no
waiting lists yeah no waiting rooms yup
boom yep if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com Lifeline today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com lifeline
saving Ryan's morning wood the what's up
Chris uh
no
dude a video game character painted it
up video game character with an 8-bit
beard dude
that beard is
Shippy yeah dude this is him
no it's just photoshopped on the screen
when he moves it like tracks and it's an
Instagram filter okay also that's common
also that's our producer Chris
a what our producer Chris
all right let's see I live in New York
City so New York we're in Timberlands
that guy's almost here nothing is more
New York than a [__] light-skinned
black dude with a dope beard and Tim's
dude this guy is like yo Bronx all day
how do you know he's wearing tents
you're saying there's no way he's not
wearing Thames I bet he's not wearing
any shoes oh he's wearing times okay go
ahead okay okay Matt my name is Adam I
live in New York City
girls out on dates
um you know I like to go China
restaurants trying to events nothing and
obviously whenever I'm on these dates I
pay for everything and that's completely
okay but the issue that I'm running into
is that when I'm on these dates I'm
trying to figure out like is this girl
actually here because she's interested
in me she sees a great handsome young
man with a great beard that's a that's a
filter that's a velcro oh no it's an
actual filter does she just want some
guy to pay for her talking you can see
its movies that night just a free date
oh it is um so I guess my question to
you is how can I figure out what their
motive is to see if it's genuine or not
um Chris I'll see you in New York on
February 18th hell yeah he's confused
about their motivation can you like give
me give me an example what he means like
what he's saying is he he wants we've
talked about this on the episode before
and you were like you kind of like
kicked back on it I was like someone
women will go on dates just because it's
a date and they get to eat food and you
still don't believe in that but dude and
then I go like this
but hoes though but that's not you're
acting like hoes don't exist that's not
a real thing that's not a thing dude
because I've never encountered in my
life or never even heard of it
from like an actual person in my life
hoes
so you're telling me this is we're just
gonna do the exact same thing we went
over on the other episode but so he's
saying how do I know here's the thing he
here's what this guy's talking about
yes sometimes a woman is just into you
and wants to hang out with you yeah
sometimes on the extreme version
if a girl's from a whole city right or
just really hard the only way reason to
do that is because you're really hungry
if she's the mayor of hoseville if she
won by a landslide to be the governor of
host city right okay okay I get it okay
right and and
she just went to eat which is not usual
okay there's that's the other end of it
but sometimes a girl is unsure if she
likes you or not yeah she's like I don't
know this guy's got to Kick-Ass beard is
a little bit of a upside down head
because he should have hair on it more
the hair should be longer on the top of
his head than it is in the bottom of his
head right so
um I don't know if I like him so let's
see what you got bro yeah well that's
normal take him out wine and dine me you
know do the thing pull out all the stops
be cool but also be a little bit
mysterious don't do everything open the
door once but not on the way home
because it's like no then maybe it's
like oh we opened the door first but
then he didn't afterwards does he not
like me anymore and then you're in the
door just open the door or you're
mysterious that's not mysterious to not
open a door it's good when you're dating
to open the door before you get to the
restaurant and then after the restaurant
you don't open the door so the chick is
like does he not like me anymore
who what kind of [__] loser are you
dude I'm just saying it what's that
guy's name the guy that used to like nag
girls mister I don't do this Siri I
could write a book on it though I know
how to you know what I mean I got
something about me that's very oh does
he like me or not
his name mystery mystery mystery that's
you no you get the nail paint and
everything your [__] Mystery Dude how
are unit is a top hat and look more like
Tommy Lee and then you're all set so
what I'm saying is that you've got to
kind of work with it and it's okay that
that a woman is like that it's okay that
a woman is like let's see what you got
right totally that's what a date is this
dude is a very handsome dude you could
tell even though he's got that [__]
but my question is is he asking how does
he tell the difference between the kind
of women who are like I want to see what
you got versus the kind of women that
like him I think what he no what what I
think is doing no strouse is even worse
what I think he's doing is saying how do
I know if a girl really likes me or not
I think that if you you know I think I
know how and I have a good I have a good
way it's better than your way okay so
uh uh all like we're on a date you're
the woman I'm the man and I'm just like
okay now I'm gonna just go we're gonna
go okay well have you seen any good
movies lately
um yeah what were they what have you
seen lately I saw blue do you really
like me
and then they'll she'll be so caught off
guard that you this show have to answer
I don't have time to think of a lie but
you I I don't you don't want to know
about Blue Streak Blue Streak was in
1998 with Martin Lawrence
and Luke Wilson
more movies or is it who I said oh wow
dude instead of playing [__] raging
[__]
oh wow wow
all right well let's do another one then
is there another light on that wasn't on
there is yeah oh the door the window's
open but that's okay we like it okay
it's nice if it's changing the aesthetic
though it's not oh is it bouncing on us
foreign okay
let's do it okay a gym floor
no I didn't hear a word you said Anthony
said I think I got Sun here outside okay
cool
what's up Chris and Matt my name is
Brian McCready and I live in Chicago
and I've been taking voice lessons for
for like two to three years and
I write songs and I do open minds and
stuff like that and it's fun
but I'm still getting better at singing
I've improved a lot but got a lot more
work to do
and I can't sing with vibrato oh and
Chris I know really you have silky
smooth vibrato
that you whip out
at a moment's notice
and it's actually it's actually really
impressive I think I think it's really
impressive uh so I want to know one of
us have you ever done voice exercises
before
you do voice exercises but but have you
or or do you have any tips for me for
developing vibrato can you show me how
to do it
all right you're a serial killer dude
yeah I thought that right when I saw it
actually actual serial killer right when
I saw him he has only killed two people
so far but in total before he gets
caught he will have killed 12.
and he'll get caught when he does like
three at once and it's too many bites
off more than he could yeah yeah he's
he's uh
the good looking dude and honestly let
me just say this so is [__] you know
congrats on here's a guy who's got a
good attitude about [__] he's doing the
work he's going to voice lessons he says
I have a lot more work to do I'm working
on my voice I'm doing open mics that's
great there are so many people that just
want to be famous and [__] yeah that
this kind of attitude is necessary and
it's like it's Fallen by the wayside now
and we understand why because people
just want the instant big and all that
[__] but um so Props to this guy here's
the other thing you don't need vibrato
you don't need vibrato of course I can
do it but there's the proof that you
don't need vibration but you don't need
to because if I was just like of course
I can do it you get the silky smooth
[__] God I honestly cannot describe how
much I hate when you do that all right
well that's more you than me look I'm
whatever I'm just saying why I hate it
why because it's it's ugly sounding what
dude yeah it's bad okay well you don't
like Roselle and me
who oh Brazil yeah I mean it's Josh
Groban's like not my thing that's all oh
and you do the group you actually don't
like that kind of stuff in general yeah
dude obviously Oh I thought it was just
me well I dislike it extra when you do
it but no I don't like vibrato okay well
I'm gonna have to keep doing it because
I especially have to do it for this one
but the dude it's fine work on it if you
want that's fine but also you don't need
to it's really dope if you can just hold
the note and [__] like just kind of
like Edge it out with no vibrato that's
awesome
I understand but but here's the thing
and I don't and this is a negative way
of saying this but I don't mean to be
negative because you can kill it like
this stay in your lane dude stay in your
[__] Lane if your lane is killer dude
Jeff Ross he does this [__] he does the
roasting that's his Lane he kills it on
that [__] he's not the guy that's gonna
come up and do political humor you
understand what I'm saying so just stay
in your lane you can make a lot of money
doing that [__]
you know what I'm saying you don't need
to be oh
you don't need to do that you can just
what I'm saying is stay in your lane
you know what I'm saying
it's ill to do that I can't do either
one right
so everyone knows I'm a better singer
than you no so my advice is by the way
dude why does everyone say that you
should get the dangly earring did I
don't know everybody online is saying
Matt to get the dang the earring not me
when I [__] decided to get the dangly
earring first because I'm it's it I I
understand why it's hard to explain it's
like maybe you won't get it because
you're not on our level oh we all
understand that it morph it fits my
Persona and my head more than it fits
yours for sure okay so it's a head thing
I think so yeah you don't look good in
hats yeah I do well how is it more of a
Persona thing or more of a head thing
uh it's a little bit of both to be
perfectly honest
if you want to know the truth it's a
little bit about it just sucks dude I
want to get it well then get it we'll
both have it but like that's on you like
I'm getting it the gay side or the
what's oh is that still a thing a right
side I don't know
I would do both I'm gonna get the gay
side okay I'm not gonna do any gay [__]
you get one I get the other one we put
our heads together it looks like we're
one head I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna I'm gonna get the gay side
is that still even a thing dude I don't
know but I'm gonna get everything dude I
mean I can't even say what I'm gonna say
but it's like yeah it was a thing George
Michael had it
[Music]
it's correlation not causation that
doesn't mean he did it because he was
gay it just means George Michael who was
gay had it well you know history is
gonna tell because probably like way
back when it wasn't gay and then it was
gay and now it's not gay and then it's
like I'm gonna get the gay side and I'm
not gonna do any gay stuff
no
okay well I'm gonna get it I I don't
even know I don't even think that's a
thing anymore honestly okay so you're
gonna get their dangly earring yes I
want to know what size you're getting
because I'm getting a bigger size he's
gonna walk around like this
uh I'm gonna get to Barry Bonds like
this
[Laughter]
if I let it go my ear stretches dude how
about the people with what Chris what do
they call the earrings with the what do
they call those again Gage dude cages
how about you get that how about you get
that you gotta start small but I
honestly do not like that that's
disgusting it's disgusting yeah but it
is cool because like you know what it is
actually really nice for is because
sometimes like with hoop earrings you
like if people have big earrings it's
blocking [__] but if you have a circle
you can and you're behind them in the
movie theater you can just watch a movie
through that I think it's good
especially when you get shot at because
you can get out of the way and then just
go like no and hold your ear up so the
Bullet goes through so necessary
all right cool yeah all right cool oh I
missed I missed bleeding all right next
one
my name is Nicole is that a tattoo
that's cool love both the podcast I
gotta get it and my question today is
about relationships so I frequently find
myself in friends with benefit
situations when I truly want a committed
relationship and so my first question is
is there anything I as the woman could
do
once I'm in a situation like that to
help progress it into a relationship or
at that point is it just too late and
follow-up question from the guy's
perspective I'm just curious what makes
you decide you want a committed
relationship versus a hookup
all right thanks love you guys wow that
is such a very sweet such a good
question it is a good question you know
why it's such a good question knew the
answers you can't because I wish I knew
the answer to the second part but which
was what part the part about what makes
you not want to advance a relationship
with some women versus uh
wanted to advance the relationship with
other women so for me I could speak with
personal experience it's it's always
been
well not always but like with Kristen
when I met Kristen I just knew
immediately immediately that this was a
woman that
you just
I wanted to be with it was immediate it
was like her energy I always describe it
as her energy you know and it was just
so obvious and so apparent and then she
gelled so well with me now has that
happened with other women before in my
past uh yeah but it hasn't always been
that sometimes you try to make a
relationship work here's the deal she's
still young and she can figure it out
it's a fair question but
um I think it's always about a thing you
I think you know really really early on
but yeah I guess but I don't know what I
see something yeah different though you
know I know I know because I'm smart but
uh I I think that the first question you
have which is like what can you do to
make to put things more on one track as
opposed to the other I think uh
uh it's I don't even know the answer to
that either to be honest but like I
think that maybe
maybe it's I mean I don't know you and I
don't know your patterns so it's harder
to say I would ask you questions if you
were still here with us but maybe it has
something to do with the fact that you
are like kind of in a hurry and one
thing that scares a lot of men is like
when they sense that the woman that
they've started to date is in a hurry to
get into a relationship it's not even
that they don't want to get in a
relationship is that they start to get a
little like scared and that makes that
sort of repels them oh it's almost like
biological physiological that a lot of
men have this thing where they're just
like oh she wants to be with me so badly
now I'm like a little bit
cautious and scared to do the same it's
almost like they don't understand why
you would want to be in a relationship
with them because yeah you know I mean
like yeah I get that yeah I I um that's
like a that's like a nice reading for
the towards them if you're looking for
something you can do generously that is
tangible uh
the only thing I say and this doesn't
necessarily work with every guy but I
think generally if you just don't rush
into bed with them if you're
specifically saying rushing to bed I'm
saying specifically don't rush into bed
with them I'm just saying specifically
don't rush broadly don't rush you're
specifically saying bad bad yes okay
because I'm saying you because you can
sleep with somebody right away but not
rush into the relationship but what I'm
saying is don't rush physically but
haven't you yes I have too so like
that's why I'm saying I'm I'm different
but I'm saying generally but I think
most oh really yeah generally I think
most guys are like that well that's
stupid it is stupid guys are dumb in
that situation in that way I think that
if you sleep with somebody first of all
like I don't think that that's bad at
all I I I've been married twice and both
times I I've been married uh that wasn't
an issue like you just you you meet them
and you know you like them immediately
and it's just Off to the Races you go at
the pace at which you feel comfortable
yes exactly and and and I think that you
can you can sleep someone on the first
night and be married to them and be have
lived long and happy with them but I
think generally guys are uh they're less
I think that generally and I think that
this is a shortcoming for men generally
is that if you meet them and you sleep
with them that they discount you and I
think that that's shitty but I think
most men are like that they think oh she
probably does that a lot uh I can't be
with a girl that does that a lot well
that sucks though because then these
stupid ass [__] guys are
basically punishing women for being
confident enough to know that they're
that they're interested correct like go
along with what their intuitions are
yeah hey guys yeah don't be like that no
I know I agree so I agree the advice
actually good question because the
advice is now for all the guys out there
just because a woman wants to have sex
with you on the earlier side of things
it doesn't mean anything about them to
like in terms of like a snap judgment
it's just every individual she wanted to
exactly I think that that's great and
healthy and if a woman does that and
knows that that's what she wants and
that's what she does then that's great
and that's that's a person that I would
want to be with because of how much they
knew about themselves and they're not
doing something because they think it's
wrong or think you know what I mean I
think it's right because they want to
everybody's different though
unfortunately you want to support your
squirt unfortunately you probably write
that most guys do yeah because guys are
[__] idiots in that way they're just
like they think in black and white [__]
or you know what I mean
yeah dude what do you mean still bro
there's still racism out there well
that's not what we're talking about but
I know but I'm saying that we progress
and people think that we're moving
forward as a country and as as a a hole
in society but we're really we're not
you know I mean we are except for
there's always going to be North Florida
yeah do you know what I'm saying yeah
so it's like yeah you can you can say
most guys most guys don't do that but
then also Jacksonville right
most guys don't do that but also Daytona
right yeah everybody don't do that but
also Tallahassee right like these are
these places that are real did you say
Jacksonville I did yeah okay yeah it was
the first one I said I'm a goldfish
don't remember [__] I don't I really so
uh I have a bad bad job so yeah I think
that if you're looking for something
tangible just don't
give it up on the first night which
sucks even if you want to it's just like
guys are idiots about that [__] but also
guys are like yeah let's do it let's do
it so what the [__] is that because
here's the deal if you ask a guy usually
generally again if you ask a guy well
meet your meet your dream girl okay in
every aspect you ask a guy you want to
sleep with her now or you want to sleep
with her in a month they're going to be
like now
then why do they take that information
and then use it hold it against them
they do that that's just why is what I'm
gonna say I don't know I'm not a [__]
psychologist but that's what happens and
then their dream girl becomes oh not
necessarily they're their dream girl
don't like that I don't like it either
that's stupid well I don't do that and
you don't do that but I'm saying guys do
that we're talking about just people
people
you know
all right all right cool two hats on all
right so yeah we'll do another one but
yeah look how much taller I look with
this well yeah you have two hats on
okay okay the worst the worst style yo
what up man Chris my name's Jason from
East Texas
more episodes but I understand having a
brother it's tough to be around them for
more than an hour yeah you know what's
up I have a question that refers back to
an older episode where the guy asked
about how to deal with Interrupters I
have a question about being the
interrupter I am the interrupter oh wow
do it good on you the reason that I do
it is so I can get my words in if I
don't I just don't get it in the
conversation Blows By Me
um at work the discussion like if I
don't agree with something or I need to
tag something in there it just doesn't
happen you know my mind doesn't work
like it used to probably due to all the
herb I used to smoke but
how do I interrupt without being a dick
would love to help thanks so much love
you guys well you can get the oops
buttons at chrisley.com and those help
and you're a dick but that's owning the
situation I'm a dick oops I'll be the
dick for you right I can tell you right
now okay
as simple as this
excuse me I'm sorry but
then you do that yeah that's what excuse
me was invented for right besides
getting it out of somebody's way you
could rip a loud fart too no
then farted but not only are you still
an [__] but you're involving your
[__] oh my God you're double [__]
oh God I farted I'm sorry I didn't mean
to but anyway what I was gonna say is
wow yeah wow worst Segway dude I I was
going to bed last night and well
actually I I put Calvin in bed Kristin's
out of town so I put Calvin in bed and
um I laid he said that were you away
with me for a bit and I laid with him
for a bit and we were just chilling and
then I hear and I go I look at him and
he goes
and I was like oh my God that's
hilarious and then I did it and then he
goes oh yuck it was really cute that now
he knows that farts are funny and also
disgusting it's true this guy's question
um I I don't there yeah you're right you
just say excuse me but but here's the
thing you get so chomping at the bit
you're this guy and you've been this guy
for so long that you get so chopped at
the bit that you're like but what I want
to say matters but here's the thing
though dude yeah you're right yeah so
you gotta you gotta work on listening
and you gotta you know and also you
gotta understand what you're gonna say
doesn't matter it doesn't that's the
thing it really doesn't that's the key
usually it doesn't matter because people
are just going to say what they're going
to say anyway so if there's an argument
basically there's a lost cause
[Applause]
wait what I don't it's a lost cause if
you're having an argument it's a lost
cause anyway nobody listens to anyone
yes
well that's like Dude people follow that
train of thought that no one would ever
talk to anybody so that's not gonna work
okay the categorical imperative says
that it's not a fruitful
selection agent Smith
categorical so what you do is either say
excuse me or just simply oh I'm sorry
but I gotta say I gotta say like address
your Interruption pardon the
[__] right you could be like
Busy Bone but just address the
interruption acknowledge the
interruption that alone makes it way
less [__] how about that for
Interruption I didn't care I bulldozed
right through that [__] rudeness
um yeah it's uh well that's nice to know
that you're an interrupter look the step
first step is you got the problem and
you realize it and you're addressing it
and that's okay uh and you got to work
on it you know but that's that those are
the two things excuse me actually
um but yeah it's the tone thing too
because Kristin always is like you got a
tone
when you say excuse me well no but I'm
like there's different ways of saying
like I just wanna can I can I say what I
was gonna say like that's all rude
though right right right but like excuse
me though but like no I understand but
excuse me sorry and I don't mean to
interrupt I still sound like a dick I
can't help it some people just have that
yeah but
be
genuinely mean sorry when you say it you
can't just say it as lip service like
you do I'm very sorry so so you could be
like I'm very sorry I understand what
you're saying yeah
um I just want to kind of throw
something in there I already sound like
a dick I can't help it I mean then don't
sound like a dick go out of your way
okay sound less like a dick
I'm sorry I just want to say why are you
Canadian why are you being Canadian I'm
so sorry um
about about what you're saying so so
then can you do it oh I'm sorry I I just
I feel like uh I have to say something
uh I'm sorry oh excuse me sorry I I'm
gonna forget if I don't say it okay okay
that sounds just as rude do you you guys
sound equally yeah I don't think he
sounds rude yeah that don't sound rude
you sound rude okay well you don't know
what you're doing because you're you I'm
listening to me okay I'm I'm sorry I
just
um I'm gonna forget oh I'm gonna forget
that see that's good here's what here's
what it is here's the difference you act
like it's all coming at you then and
you're apologizing for that you're not
just like oh and yeah oh I'm sorry oh
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna think
of this right now you're a piece of [__]
yeah that's it that's perfect you're a
piece of [__] that's perfect what you're
saying is shitty yeah that's great yeah
um yeah honestly though he's right the
the it's so important we all have our
shortcomings and it's so important to
understand what those are and not think
that we're up to Snuff in every [__]
possible Department because nobody is
and people who think they're like as
this as everyone else and as that
everyone else or as the best of them
it's just not true nobody's the best at
everything and so like people that
aren't for instance people who aren't
funny and know they're not funny
automatic leg up on everybody else who
isn't funny and thinks that they're
funny
hold on people that are dumb and are
like I'm not that smart
they're better than people who are dumb
and think they're smart right right
right right right right
yeah just two examples yeah yeah true
everybody kind of so it applies to this
guy who's like oh man I'm a dick I
interrupt but like I don't want to be so
that already makes you better and so
when you interrupt you will already be
less of a [__] [__] when you do
yeah yeah yeah feel that that's it
that's what you're working with feel
that feel that what you're you know you
sent in a video to Lifeline feel that
what you felt when you sent a Lifeline
when you're having a conversation with
somebody there we go we did it picture
my face
picture my face put your my green beanie
picture my [__] Ab Fab shirt that
says I'm Patsy Stone I'm 39. okay
all right picture Matt yeah okay well
look I'm gonna be in New York I'm gonna
be in Louisiana tonight I'm gonna be in
New York uh in two weeks in Chicago
uh Boise uh Minneapolis God it would be
great if you put up my thing right uh or
hard s on Boise huh Boise yeah that's
still doing that okay you gotta you
that's how that's what it is okay okay
so Providence Rhode Island uh uh Kansas
City Springfield is a Tulsa Midland
Texas Austin two shows there in Austin
Cincinnati we're killing it dude we're
having a good time Chris Lea Don't Push
Me Tour uh and uh I put some clips of my
stand up up on my Chrisley official
Channel go check those out thanks a lot
guys Micro Machines uh magically.com for
one-on-one sessions with
me matalia talk about your problems give
specific one-on-one advice we go back
and forth with it it's a more
personalized book me now matchally.com
and get your merch at what is it
lifelinemerch.com and yeah if you have a
question click in the uh to click the
link in the description below or go to
watch lifeline.com
[Music]